c'est facile d'être c'est plus facile
d'être ministre aujourd'hui et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser à
tutti vement que de l'être par le passé
puisque c'est une politique du carnet de
chèques et des pensées quand on fait le
ségur de la santé on dépense beaucoup
quand on ne veut pas comme nouveau
ministre de la justice dit j'ai obtenu
des crédits supplémentaires
donc il ya un sujet quand même
extrêmement important qui est de de quoi
qu'il en coûte mais quoi qu'il en coûte
un peu borné au fond il n'y a pas
d'argent magistrat il n'y a pas de dette
magique non plus il n'y a pas de dette
comme ça qui va me voilà plutôt un
partisan de l'orthodoxie budgétaire non
ça veut rien dire il n'ya pas
d'orthodoxie budgétaire l'orthodoxie
budgétaire française si le déficit
l'orthodoxie budgétaire française c'est
je dépense et puis à quelqu'un qui
remboursera plus farm ne me répondent à
aucune de lady mary 2 et là dessus hier
y ait eu un accord européen qui est un
accord important quand on est européen
qu'on a une conviction européenne compte
notamment la conviction que le destin de
la france il s'inscrit quand même dans
un destin européen
on peut se réjouir de cet accord
maintenant il ya des évidements des
points d'interrogation des questions une
fois qu'on aura emprunté 750 milliards
d'euros je rappelle que le budget
européen
c'est un peu plus de 1000 milliards sur
sept ans donc c'est des sommes
considérables
rapporté au budget il faudra rembourser
le remboursement n'est pas très établis
dans cet accord il ya un énorme flou
c'est évidemment un peu problématique on
ne sait pas si rare un impôt qui sera
créée sur le plan européen pour
rembourser ces sommes gigantesques
le président de la république a évoqué
des pistes on les connaît tous un cd
grosso modo toujours à taxe carbone aux
frontières
mais justement m évidemment aussi mais
ça ne suffira pas des revenus douaniers
ça peut être des taxes sur le numérique
enfin on ne peut être là des taxes sur
les transactions financières auxquelles
ont recours depuis bien longtemps
est ce que c'est un manque certain point
d'interrogation très important je note
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
points d'interrogation un autre point
d'interrogation c'est qu'une partie des
crédits se fera au détriment du budget
global
il ya des programmes à l'aurore g
erasmus pour les nations dites étudiants
oui mais le problème de santé aussi
et la volonté d'avoir des réponses de
santé préparation commune collective à
des situations de crise sanitaire comme
nous l'avions ces programmes sont
aujourd'hui réduits voire supprimés
la défense le climat le climat le climat
donc on verra dans les six ou sept ans
parce qu'au delà de cet accord il
d'accord sur un budget sur six ou sept
ans et ce budget est plus réduit qui
n'apparaissait enfin que que prévu donc
il ya des points d'interrogation et des
paradoxes dans cet accord vous avez
accumulé des séries plan alors on
n'avait qu'une et plans sectoriels
aéronautique l'automobile le tourisme
des plans d'urgence
oui un plan on les a votés donc la
droite a montré qu'elle était évidemment
capable à un moment donné de dépasser
les clivages politiques mais tout d'un
coup on est dans la relance mais la
vérité c'est qu'on devrait dans la
relance depuis déjà longtemps comme
d'autres d'autres pays
et ce n'est pas le cas quand tu joues si
tu essaies ses plans sectoriels compte
regarder les jolies j'ai regardé les
jeunes on est les premiers
je ne cherche pas de test en recherche
de paternité on est les premiers des
lapointe du mois d'avril à avoir pointé
du doigt l'idée qu'il y avait des
générations de jeunes qui allait arriver
sur le marché du travail
et personne ne s'en occupait et on a dit
au gouvernement vous faudra quand même
que vous vous en occuper on l'a dit de
façon parfois deux oui tant mieux comme
on dit est venu oui mais les jeunes
matesi rentrer maintenant sur le marché
du travail y rentrer dans le budget
rectificatif qu'on est en train de voter
le troisième à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat en ce moment dans ce budget on
vient juste d'intégrer un certain nombre
de crédits pour le dernier trimestre
dans un processus d' aide aux jeunes
qu'on connaît pas encore mais ce qui est
très important c'est à la fois d'engager
des mouvements de transformation
rénovation énergétique etc tout ça on
sait et il faut le faire je trouve que
le gouvernement aurait dû le faire à
cette occasion au mois de mai au mois de
juillet qui veulent marquer la rentrée
par un coup d'éclat peut-être je ne sais
pas au moins 2 à la fin du mois d'août
et qui va donner le tempo politique delà
de la rentrée je peux peut-être le
comprends mais je pense que les
gouvernements qui aime beaucoup
d'enchaînements et sacré
ça crée pas de la clarté si vous voulez